estamos ante dos noticias que parecen
chocar una con la otra por un lado Se
confirma que habrá una segunda vuelta el
20 de agosto como estaba previsto Pero
por otro lado se anula la personalidad
jurídica del partido de Arévalo quisiera
preguntarle en primer lugar qué alcance
tiene y qué representa esta medida para
el candidato
Bueno yo creo que es parte de la
incertidumbre que hemos tenido en este
proceso electoral donde hay una
judicialización de todo el proceso
político con una intromisión directa del
de la justicia sobre todo de algunos de
algunos tribunales para para retrasar el
proceso por ejemplo hemos tardado mucho
en conocer la oficialización de los
resultados precisamente por una acción
de la corte de constitucionalidad este
el la denuncia que se hace el día de hoy
pues para nosotros es el es el lo que
llamamos una patada de ahogado del
sistema
de sobre todo del del presidente y de y
de los aliados que tiene para evitar el
que se pueda jugar en la segunda vuelta
el partido semilla más que todo porque
semia ha representado o el voto hacia
semilla y además el voto que ganó que
fue el voto nulo ha representado el
rechazo de los ciudadanos al sistema en
general y sobre todo al este gobierno
que ha puesto sobre la mesa la práctica
de la judicialización y el ataque a los
opositores a través del mecanismos de
Justicia sin embargo después de la de de
que el tribunal supremo electoral
hiciera el anuncio Pues realmente
responde al tribunal supremo supremo
electoral el el poder Cancelar o no
cancelar un partido del poder
suspenderlo o no sin embargo la ley
electoral que tiene Rango constitucional
dice que ningún partido puede ser
suspendido durante un proceso electoral
así que nosotros estaríamos esperando
que el tribunal supremo electoral tenga
la última palabra en este proceso
cuéntenos bueno porque Estos son medidas
que colocan con bastante incertidumbre
No solo a ustedes sino más todavía a
quienes no somos de su país verdad
estamos ante decisiones que involucran a
dos instituciones por un lado hablamos
del tribunal supremo electoral por otro
lado del Ministerio Público cuéntenos
sobre todo nuestra internacional que es
el Ministerio Público Qué funciones
tiene y qué ocurre cuando tomaba medidas
que chocan con las de otras
instituciones como en este caso
bueno el Ministerio Público es la
fiscalía lo que puede hacer la fiscalía
general en otros países excelente
acusador por parte del Estado e
investigador sin embargo la fiscal
actual que está a cargo del ministerio
público que ha sido ratificada por el
presidente Ian maté y ha sido señalada
en dos oportunidades por Estados Unidos
por ser un actor corrupto y estar en
contra de la democratización y y socavar
los procesos democráticos es decir
tenemos una fiscal que fue ratificada a
pesar de ser señalada como un actor
corrupto por parte de Estados Unidos
ella ha sido la gran aliada del
presidente para perseguir en este caso y
el mismo juez que ahora intenta
entrometerse en el proceso electoral
este juez es el que metió a la cárcel al
periodista José Rubén Zamora por digamos
en en un juicio sin ningún fundamento
Así mismo ha perseguido a varios
Fiscales que están en este momento en el
exilio o es decir el el Ministerio
Público es un actor al Servicio del
presidente para
entrometerse en prácticamente todos los
procesos y perseguir a sí mismo a los
opositores políticos Carmen nos queda
poco tiempo pero no quiero dejar de
realizarle la siguiente pregunta que le
queda ahora Arévalo o qué le quedará qué
alternativas tendrá para seguir en la
contienda electoral bueno en principio
suponemos que el tribunal supremo
electoral cumpliendo la ley electoral no
puede cancelar el partido ni puede
suspender ningún partido creo que además
en este momento hay una gran
movilización
la la ciudadanía se está movilizando
porque lo ve precisamente esta contienda
como el último resquicio que tenemos
como guatemaltecos para rechazar el el
pacto de corruptos como la llamamos
rechazar la impunidad en el país y hacer
un cambio Así que yo creo que se está
jugando con fuego en este caso por parte
del presidente y de la fiscal general
porque sí están creo que va a haber
mucha movilización en el país y también
podemos asistir pues alguna ruptura
constitucional